un bon soir alain
merci d'être avec nous à la situation
que vit actuellement l'afrique du sud 1
qui suspend rappelle non sans son
programme de vaccination astrazeneca
on imagine que c'est une décision de bon
sens qui n'est pas en soi critiquable
mais lourde de conséquence on l'a vu
puisque on commande avant de connaître
l'efficacité notamment sur ces variants
est ce que c'est une situation qui
pourrait se reproduire notamment en
europe
je suppose que oui ce qui se passe ces
camions de vaccins qui commande et de
laine que le plus grand producteur de
vin au monde
les tests ont été faits malheureusement
les résultats sont sortis après la
commande mais bon on pourrait pas
attendre de la cour la course contre la
monte pour que chaque payer ses taxes à
temps les autorités sud africaines ont
pris la bonne décision selon vous elle
n'avait pas franchement le choix
franchement le soir exactement ce qu'ils
aimeraient fait c'est renvoyé les
vaccins si ça va être possible
il ya une autre compagnie johnson
johnson qui va donner le vaccin dans les
semaines qui vont venir
apparemment efficacité serait de 60 60 %
66 % par rapport à astrazeneca qui est
de 22%
aujourd'hui vous parler de johnson &
johnson quels sont les autres aux
alternatives en afrique du sud
concernant ces vaccins il y en a
d'autres pour été précommandés je ne
suis pas au courant je pense que celle
là est la plus la plus probable
en tout cas sera zenica malheureusement
pas efficace sur ce variant sud africain
mais aussi et on le constate aussi en
europe sur les personnes les plus âgées
globalement c'est une efficacité de je
dirais entre nîmes et évidemment
seulement 70% par rapport à d'autres
vaccins comme le faiseur ou comme le
russe en scoot nique
v1 qui affiche plus de 91 % d'efficacité
finalement c'est pas idéal quand on
reçoit le vaccin d'astrazeneca on peut
quand même s'en réjouir mieux vaut mieux
le faire c'est que rien du tout
apparemment les gens qui ont été
vaccinés parce que six mille personnes
qui ont été vaccinées
il n'y a pas eu d'hospitalisation
donc il ya un effet mais la contagion
reste des gens qui ont été vaccinés sont
reste contagieux je continue à répandre
le virus mais sont immunisés donc ce que
vous nous direz la vente que vous nous
dicte docteur avance assez intéressant
vous avez fait vous êtes un homme de
terrain un médecin généraliste ce que
vous constatez avec ses premiers
vaccinés c'est que ça enlève la gravité
de la forme de co vide mais ça
concrètement non mais n'empêche pas de
transmettre ce virus c'est bien c'est
bon on l'a conduit à se protéger à se
masquer à ce service est lavé les mains
etc
les précautions nécessaires mais le
problème reste malheureusement
aujourd'hui les patients que vous
recevez dans votre cabinet qu'est ce que
vous constatez comme un symptôme est ce
qu'ils sont différents de la touche
graphique non pas les symptômes soient
les mêmes ma seule différence est qu'il
semble réglé ça beaucoup plus contagieux
que la première vague
alors aujourd'hui à ces vaccins il ya
aussi le protocole renforcé en tout cas
c'est le cas en france quelle est la
situation sur le front des mesures en
afrique du sud
le masque est obligatoire dans les
endroits publics ya un couvre-feu à
partir de 11h jusqu'à 6h du matin y a
pas de vent d'alcool les restaurants
restent ouverts les endroits publics
restent ouverts
mais voilà les salles de gymnastique
sont ouvertes ya pas de sport pas de
combien les compétitions mais si on
public évidemment comme en euros comme
en europe donc merci en tout cas nous
avoir exposé à saluer un médecin
généraliste en afrique du sud
la situation du côté de johannesburg ce
soir merci à vous